if you are chasing something just
because you think it's an opportunity
and you have no genuine passion for it
stop right now it's a waste of time
you're like evolving we like changing we
don't want to sit at the same desk and
do the same work for 25 years you need
to be consistent today we're going to
talk about the seven ways to win on
social media
[Music]
what's that believe nation it's heaven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out under the world now this special
edition of seven ways is brought to you
by the workshop that I'm running in May
May 23rd to May 25th on how to make
money from your ideas where I'm sharing
my breakdown how I make money how you
can to basically be the Evan Carmichael
of your industry and start to dominate
and be a thought leader and lead from
the front if you're interested the link
is in the description we are about 40%
sold though right now and looking for 15
amazing people that I can sink my hooks
into and really drive forth some value
from in May but one of the big things
that entrepreneurs often ask me is how
do I win on social media what are the
some of the things I need to keep in
mind and this is one of the things I'm
talking about at my workshop and thought
I'd give you kind of a high-level
overview in this video today we number
one is have emotional commitment one of
the most important things that I learned
from the $10,000 us that I spent on
media training that really helped
transform my channel if you go back on
my channel and look at how I started and
how awkward and nervous I was compared
to where I'm and now it's not just doing
the wraps it's not just doing 5,000
videos but learning and training
emotional commitment so the people come
to the workshop in Toronto this is going
to be one of the big things that we work
on I need you to care more about your
message and I know you do I know you
care about your message but when you get
in front of the camera a lot of times it
does not come out the words are coming
out the value is coming out your your
strategies and your technologies are
coming out but the passion the
importance the commitment is not coming
out and it doesn't mean you always have
to be yelling and excited and you know
passion is my superpower
it just means that every word you say
has to mean something you have to be
emotionally committed to the message
that you are given and that can be
really hard because when you're talking
from the camera how do you get excited
how do you turn up how did you make it
more important one of the most important
lessons that I learned was imagine that
somebody's on a bridge and they're about
to jump off and your message is the last
thing that they are going to hear before
they do that and so you have to really
sway them and so my agent would always
tell me up the stakes up the stakes
raise the stakes raise the stakes it has
to be more important because for most
people it's not going to be that
important it's not gonna be a life in
that situation but for some people that
will be for some people I've had people
who comment on my channel that the video
that they watched saved their life and
that sounds crazy but it's true and
unless you bring that level of emotional
commitment to the message that you're
saying unless you fully believe it and
are feeling it as you're saying it you
could have the best words in the world
but they will not resonate because
people can tell that you're not
committed to it and so a lot of times
when people are trying to make content
they're so worried about seeing the
right words they're so worried about
getting their script perfect and this
was me too if you like my girlie videos
I'm looking up to the left a lot I'm
trying to memorize a script and it comes
off as super pained because I'm just
trying to memorize the words I'm trying
to focus on getting the exact words that
I wrote down on a piece of paper instead
of actually feeling the message and
going with that emotional commitment to
the message is so so so so so so
important you have to incorporate it if
you want to win on social media way
number two is be consistent this is a
boring one but you need to be consistent
four years ago I had seven thousand
subscribers on my youtube channel four
years later at 1.2 million and growing
how does that happen well I had content
that was I was emotionally committed to
but it was consistent we've made 2 to 3
videos every day for the past 4 years I
can't remember the last day in 4 years
that we took off that we did not post a
video and so it's being consistent one
of the things that people will always
recognize me for just being consist
it's not just me it's everybody
everybody's had success in any field
athletics entrepreneurship music you're
consistent there was a great analogy I
heard about if somebody's trying to cook
pasta or cook some rice in a bottle in a
bottle that's amazing cooking rice in a
bottle water cooking rice and pasta in a
in a pot of water and you put it on the
stove and then you turn it up and then
it's on for five seconds and you turn
the stove off and you five minutes later
you turn the stove on again for five
seconds and then you turn it off if you
do that you're never gonna you never
gonna boil the pasta you never gonna
bowl the the water you never going to
get food to eat and that's what most
people do with their social media
content or even with their business you
start and you stop and you start and you
stop and you start and you stop but you
don't allow for the momentum to grow you
need to be consistent it's much more
important that you are making one piece
of content every single day and learning
and growing from it because I'm a big
believer one in momentum but two that
the quantity leads to the quality that
the more you do it the better you will
get and you allow time for people to get
to know you and notice you and love you
and want to follow you and share your
stuff you need to be consistent if you
don't believe me follow me and Instagram
now it took me a number of years to get
to 6,000 followers and in a couple
months I hit 10,000 and now I'm growing
because I'm emotionally committed to it
I'm being consistent in my content and
four years later I'm going to win and so
it's been insanely impatient like every
piece of content has to matter this
video has to be amazing but the to the
best of my abilities with the skill sets
I have the Instagram content I put up
every post has to be the best that I can
post with the abilities that I have and
I'm patient in that I know it's going to
take me three four years to ultimately
get to a big spot and so the consistency
is really important and a lot of you are
not consistent enough in making amazing
content you think that you make one
great video that you put a lot of time
into and that's going to be the thing
it's not you have to keep going every
single day
amazing amazing content
[Music]
way number three is reply to every
comment reply to every comment across
every platform everywhere that you are
you need to reply to comments and that's
easy in the early days when I first
started my youtube channel I didn't get
any comments for the video you know if
one in ten videos got to come and I was
happy and somebody left a comment this
is amazing so it's easy it's easy for
the small channels to do it it's easy
when nobody's paying attention to you to
respond to every comment it's still
important because when you respond to a
comment they're much more likely to
subscribe they're much more likely to be
really engaged in your future your
future content they're much more likely
to share with their friends you want to
be on top of all of those early comments
but don't stop as you build as you grow
comments have to be responded to now I
don't think you need to respond to every
comment yourself as you get bigger
you can't like physically I can't
physically I don't have enough time in
the day to respond to every single
comment not because I'm so important and
I've so many things happening there's
just not enough time in a day there's so
many comments coming in that physically
it's not possible for one person to
respond to every single comment so you
build a team and when people respond to
my comments for me they put their name
at the end so it's not confused in
between which ones I'm responding to and
which one other people are responding to
just like any other business I don't
understand how people in social media
can't treat their accounts like a
business maybe because a lot of times
this might be their first business but
if if you have a flower store and
somebody calls you and leaves a message
what do you do you call them back right
or if somebody emails you you email them
back right it's the exact same thing if
somebody is a comment you comment back
you respond you acknowledge them and if
you had that flower store it doesn't
mean that you have to serve every single
customer yourself that's why you hire a
team right as you grow you hire your
team they can help you respond to things
but at the earlier days for any of you
guys watching you know if you're under a
hundred comments a day across everything
right between YouTube and Twitter and
Facebook and LinkedIn and everything if
you're under a hundred comments a day do
it yourself I respond to a hundred
comments a day
you have to do it yourself do it do it
do it do it do it do it one it gets you
really close to your your audience gets
you really close to your customers so
you understand them you get to know them
and and they feel really connected to
you and to the more that you do it the
more that if you're doing it early
somebody on your team if you're beyond
the hundred plus then you're building
momentum then they're feeling recognized
and they're much more likely to share
your message
bonus tip on number three here I love
leaning in on the personal video
messages and so if you send me a Twitter
message if you tweet at me or if you
send me an Instagram DM or if you send
me a snapchat DM I'm likely at least
once gonna respond with the video
because I want you to know that it's me
and I want you to know that I read your
thing and I want you to see my face and
I want you to hear me say your name and
hear me say the answer and I can deliver
a message like this much better with
emotional commitment much better in a
video format then I can brighten it up
and so I want people to get that
experience and so I've leaned in much
more impersonally responding to people
on Twitter on Instagram on snapchat
because I can because I can make a video
response or LinkedIn Facebook YouTube he
came it's kind of crazy that YouTube
being a video platform you can't make
video responses I used to do video
responses this is how crazy I get over
this stuff I would make a video response
for a number of people individually and
I've record an unlisted video on YouTube
and then send it to them in the comments
but they don't get notified a lot of
times in the comments a bunch of issues
there and YouTube you gotta fix that you
can't make a video response your video
network anyway I digress respond to
every single comment
ideally in video format unless it does
have to be polished you know I'm making
this video in my car
most of my DMS and my Twitter messages
and all that I'm making a while I'm on
the bike in my workout room so I spent
35 minutes four times a week typically
on the bike and that's what I'm doing
I'm on the bike and to help pass the
time I spend it with you guys I respond
and people say can't believe you
responded have a great workout really
appreciate the message and it doesn't
take long some of them are 10 seconds 20
seconds 30 seconds it doesn't have to
take a long time and
make such an important impact for them
to hear from you who they look up to
respect see as a thought leader as an
expert it just winds so much loyalty
karma is always practical and I highly
recommend that you do it respond to
every comment weight number four is to
test test test test test test test test
test this is name of the game you got a
test you got to see what's working and
see what's not working and adjust
constantly on my youtube channel which
is a little more mature than my other
platforms we're still testing we still
test every series for example has to
lead the positive subscribers and
significant watch time YouTube cares
about watch time that's their number-one
metric so I now care about watch time I
care about subscriber growth I want to
make sure that every new series we make
is generating subscribers for the
channel and so what I'll do as a test is
for any new series I put out we will
give it at least three runs one month
two months three months three times and
then we check the data is it working do
people like it are we getting positive
watch time on it does it compare well to
my other videos on the channel is it
leaving two subscriber growth so by
watching this video YouTube will tell
you per video how many subscribers you
got and so I want to know over this
three test period did we gain
subscribers because of this series and
if not then we kill it and we experiment
with something new and so you're
constantly testing on Instagram right
now since that's a newer platform for me
there's been a lot more tests a lot more
innovation a lot more changes I try this
okay this isn't working let's try this
doesn't work let's try this doesn't work
and with Instagram you also get a lot
more instant data I see oh dude that
they're pretty good instant instant
right instant data and also because I
don't know as much and making a lot more
mistakes and that's great
this constant experimentation I have one
guy my team who's helping me make the
content where I'm helping direct him and
say do this do this do this do this and
one week at something next week that
Alstead strategy last week gone let's
try this now we're trying this and so
you get that by testing testing testing
testing will help you improve forever
and always and you need to apply it
across all your social media platforms
you pick the metric or two that you care
the most about and then you
test your content against it
consistently to try to find a winning
formula rule number five is remember
it's a balance between you and the
audience you have to create content that
you love you have to put out a message
that means something to you back to the
emotional commitment you have to put out
content that means something to you and
it has to mean something to the audience
it has to move the people in your
network it's got to be something that
they actually care about ask me that
combination of the both if you only make
stuff that you love but nobody else
cares you have a hobby like you love
making videos great it's a worthwhile
hobby but it's not gonna help you grow
your business not gonna help you get
speaking gigs it's not gonna help you be
a thought leader but it's a hobby which
may be enough for you but if it's not
then you have to pay attention to the
audience if you're only paying attention
to the audience and you don't care about
that material then you lose as well if
you're only making content because silly
cat videos does well on YouTube and you
try to make silly cat videos you're
gonna lose
you'll lose it's the wrong strategy
don't just chase an opportunity because
the people who love making silly cat
videos will destroy you because they
love it and you don't the people who
love doing the work will always crush
you compared to the people who are just
doing the Chasen opportunity and apply
that not just a social media but across
life across business if you are chasing
something just because you think it's an
opportunity and you have no genuine
passion for it stop right now it's a
waste of time and so it's the money it's
a waste of energy it's a waste of
resources you will lose because the
people who love doing that will crush
you and so just do the thing that you
love and there's an audience for that
match is where you will always always
always always always always win
[Music]
we're number six is to collaborate this
one I hesitated to be honest putting on
the list it depends on the social media
network collaborations work better in
some social media networks over others
one of the fastest ways to grow any
business is to find people who are
already connected to your target
audience
I find a way to work together not just
social media but in business find
somebody who already has your target
audience and then find a way to work
together so for me if I'm looking at I
want to target entrepreneurs it's great
to collaborate my first collaborations
were with Tim Schmoyer and Derral Eve's
who have YouTube data YouTube
explanation how to kind of channels and
I've collaborated with Gary Vaynerchuk
and Grant Cardone
and a bunch of people who are all in the
entrepreneur space lots of them that are
all over my channel and it's great
because we have similar audiences it
would not be as beneficial for me to
collaborate with a kids toy channel
because those are not the people that
I'm trying to reach that being said I
found at least especially in the YouTube
world collaborations are only really
worth it what if you love it the
collaborations can be a labor of love
and it's great to be able to you know do
something new involve different people
on the channel but - if either it's a
low investment time for you or the
person you're collaborating with is just
so much bigger than you that it really
pays off what I found that is if
somebody is around the same size as you
or smaller it's not often worth it just
because you'll get a little bit of
subscriber growth from them but for the
amount of time that goes into it it's
just not worth it's just not worth it
and so a lot of the people that I do
collaborations with I just have them on
my channel we do a hangouts video it's
live I might be on their channel doing
an interview it's live it doesn't
require as much work or for out an
events if we're I go over here to event
called clemmer Khan in Palm Springs
California and they're a bunch of
different collaborations end up
happening it's easy because everybody's
at one spot it's easy to grab somebody
and make a video off to the side and
grab somebody else to make a video but
to fly and go meet somebody to make a
collaboration video is usually not worth
and less again they
way bigger than you and gaining those
thousand subscribers from them to you
makes a big difference because you only
have 100 subscribers and so I think
collaborations can be really important
you just have to weigh one how much do
you love them how much do you enjoy
meeting other people and doing it as
just a creative expression and then 2
how much time is it actually gonna take
you to do it versus that time spent on
making other videos anyway number 7 the
last one I have for you guys today is
evolve constantly one of the biggest
challenges of any business but
especially social media is being able to
continue to express your voice and
change what ends up happening especially
when you're doing testing testing
testing data data data is you find a
winning formula the thing is that
winning formula won't last forever not
because the market doesn't like it but
because you grow tired of it
entrepreneurs we like doing different
things we like trying new stuff we like
experimenting we like we like evolving
and we like changing we don't want to
sit at the same desk and do the same
work for 25 years and so a big challenge
for entrepreneurs is when they hit a
strategy that starts working for them
then they feel like they have to keep
going and doing it and at the beginning
that's really excited and new and
different and you love it and you're
adjusting but then you feel often that
you get locked in I can't tell you how
many creators I've met where they feel
trapped by their past success they
become successful doing one thing and
now they feel trapped by it and they
can't grow and do something else what
you create should always be an extension
of yourself the top tens for example I
love making them I still enjoy I still
learn from it the second that I hate the
top tens the second making top 10 videos
for me is work it's like oh I got to
make another top 10 video I'm done it's
out I will not make top tens anymore one
of you guys can take the mantle be the
new top 10 rules for success you'll have
my blessing but I still love doing it
and so I think you need to pay really
close attention to the work that you
love doing the activities that you
really appreciate and as you evolve and
grow as a human being as you get new
interest new creativity new awareness as
you want to come up and try new things
you have to put that into your channel
you have to put that into you the
content that you are putting up because
if you're not doing it you're gonna get
increasingly frustrated increasingly
bored with what you're doing on your
channel because the problem is you have
grown as a human being with interests
and desires and passion and interest and
your channels stayed here your content
is stayed here because the chains of
success have held you back where you
need to be like the Beatles
every album from the Beatles was
different had a different sound had a
different flavor
and some people may say you know what I
like I like your early stuff better I
don't like what you did any more stuff
we're not going back to that that's not
who we are anymore we've grown so come
and grow with us or just keep listening
to our pack catalog you're up here now
you've gone and changed you need to
bring your channel up here with you and
ideally ideally it's not this big chasm
it's not this big jump it's you're both
here at the start right you're here your
channels here you grow your channel
growth you grow your channel growth you
evolve your channel vols right it's this
constant back and flow as soon as you
get an idea to try something you do it
and you're training your audience if you
go from here to here right Europe you're
appearing now you make a drastic change
you're gonna lose a huge chunk of your
audience because they're not used to
this up here and that's terrifying and
the more you grow and expand the more
people you're going to lose so it keeps
you down here it keeps you frustrated
and angry and so you need to constantly
evolve and change the content you're
putting up that's a constant reflection
of who you are as you evolve your
business your content needs to evolve as
well so those are my seven ways on how
to win on social media again the content
is brought to you by the workshop I'm
putting on in May 23rd to 25th on how to
make money from your ideas this is a
high-level overview I'm gonna go way
more in depth on how to actually do it
at the event and I'm gonna work with you
to do it this isn't just going to be
strategy in theory we're gonna get in
front of the camera and we're gonna make
content we're gonna get on your cell
phone we're gonna make content you're
gonna get in front of my camera crew and
we're gonna make content and I'm gonna
be behind the camera directing you and
say try this try this
I need more emotional commitment and
then my team is also gonna
help you edit we're gonna edit the
videos and give you a final cut that you
can use on your channel and on your
website
so hopefully you some of you guys will
come out again if you want to be a
thought leader you want to make money
from your ideas this is the best thing
for you to go to if you want to be
behind the scenes and just be an
entrepreneur and not be the face this is
not for you please do not sign up I want
to work with fifteen people who want to
lead from the front and be the experts
and change the world making money doing
it link is in the description
already 40% sold out and I'm super
pumped so again get my hooks into you
and over the three days that we have
together make a difference make a change
thank you guys so much for watching I
would love again to know which of these
seven ways you're going to apply to your
business immediately which was the most
valuable or interesting and is there an
eight nine ten that you want to add to
the list on top to bring more value to
believe nation leaving the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is
much love I'll see you soon raise your
standard Apple at the cool its core
value is that passion not one drop of
most self-worth depends on your it's
something cement i don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
Rose a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details